le problème de l'homosexualité n'avait
jamais été abordé à la télévision avant
1975 ce sont en effet les dossiers de
l'écran qui en ont parlé les premiers à
la télévision en janvier 1975 je pense
d'ailleurs que beaucoup d'entre vous se
souviennent de cette émission qui a vécu
à l'époque un grand retentissement elle
avait été précédée d'un film et les
invités les amitiés particulières pardon
et les invités les invités principaux
étaient roger peyrefitte yves navarre et
jean louis borie c'était la première
fois que des hommes que des écrivains
venait à la télévision déclaré à visage
découvert qu'ils étaient homosexuels
jusqu'à présent on peut dire que jusque
là on peut dire que le sujet avait été
plus ou moins tabou et que les
homosexuels d'une façon générale
indépendamment de la télévision était
plus ou moins réduit à une sorte de
clandestinité
nous en sommes aujourd'hui en 1984 dix
ans ont passé et il semble qu'en ce qui
concerne les ventes l'homosexualité les
choses aient considérablement évolué
l'homosexuel se déclarent peu volontiers
il arrive même que certains d'entre eux
s'affichent
il y à des radios homosexuels il ya une
presse homosexuels il y à des lieux de
rencontres qui font volontiers leur
propre publicité et ils semblent ils
sont jeunes et bien il semble que de son
côté la société admettent plus
volontiers le phénomène homosexuels
jeudi il semble parce qu'en fait c'est
la question qui sera ce soir au coeur de
notre débat la question savoir quelle
place occupe aujourd'hui en 1984 le mot
sexuelle et comment la société le
considèrent pour illustrer notre
émission de ce soir nous avons retenu un
film dont le propos je dis bien le
propos est plutôt plus audacieux que
celui des amitiés particulières
puisqu'il raconte l'histoire d'un jeune
homme qui découvre l'homosexualité de
son père notre émission marque également
le retour ce soir au direct c'est-à-dire
que vous pourrez tout à leur exprimer
vos sentiments sur le problème que nous
allons traiter ce soir posez toutes les
questions vous voudrez et gilbert call
qui se trouve asvp pour nous ce soir
sera votre intermédiaire et il établira
avec nous avec nos invités ici indien
ses invités je voudrais vous les
présenter en commençant par jocelyne
françois joue une françois est une un
poète une romancière qui a été mariée
pendant sept ans mariage qui a donné
naissance à trois enfants mais qu'elle a
rompu pour vivre avec marie-claire une
amie de l'adolescence et cette rencontre
et cet amour pour marie claire que je
sais une françois raconte dans son roman
joue nous espada qui a été couronnée par
le jury féminin en 1981 dominique
fernandez lui aussi est écrivain il a
obtenu en 1974 le prix médicis avec
porporino ou les mystères de naples et
le prix goncourt en 1982 avec un livre
intitulé dans la main de l'ange
il a été marié il a deux enfants et il a
écrit un autre roman s'intitule l'étoile
rose pour affirmer sur l'homosexualité
eu beau marsan est également écrivain il
est également journaliste au gai pied le
guêpier s'écrit en deux mots c'est un
hebdomadaire homosexuels et hugo marsan
est l'auteur d'un livre enquête
intitulée un homme un homme sur les
comportements et les modes de vie du
monde gay ce qui signifie homosexuels
maintenant d'un mot qui nous vient
d'amérique mais qui est couramment
utilisée sur le monde gay sur le monde
homosexuel dans notre société
renaud camus un écrivain qui lui aussi a
collaboré au gai pied pour lequel il a
signé des chroniques régulières sur
l'homosexualité qu'il a réunis dans un
ouvrage intitulé les chroniques
acridienne paru cette année
le docteur didier ce qui est médecin
psychiatre qui est membre du groupe de
travail sur le sida le sida est en cette
maladie terrible dont beaucoup de mots
sexuelles ont été victimes et enfin
monsieur paul veyne qui est historien
qui est sociologue et professeur au
collège de france et qui a notamment
étudié l'homosexualité dans l'antiquité
gréco-romaine deux des invités que nous
accueillons ce soir sur le plateau de
dossiers de l'écran ont connu je dirais
même connaissent vivent cette situation
qui est évoqué par le film d'une part
dominique fernandez qui a été mariée
pendant dix ans qui a eu deux enfants de
ce mariage et qui a quitté son épouse
pour les vivre avec un garçon et d'autre
part je suis françois qui
a été elle même mariée aussi pendant
sept ans et qui a quitté son mari après
avoir eu trois enfants de ce mariage
pour aller vivre avec une jeune femme il
dit lequel a raconté d'ailleurs dans un
livre qui s'appelle jou nou et span a
alors qu'est ce que vous pensez de la
situation qui est évoqué par le film non
pas du film en tant que tel peut importe
mais de la situation qui était moqué là
enfin vous avez connu enfin moi je crois
que j'ai agi moins adroitement fais-moi
sottement que ce personnage je suis dit
que le père que le père qui a attendu
beaucoup trop longtemps et qui est en
cash sur la chose on a fait un abcès et
une choses dramatiques
c'est comme un enfant si on lui dit les
choses ou celui fait comprendre même si
on le dit elle pas me le dire sur monde
convient qu'on est heureux il convient
bien que soient hétéros ou homos
l'enfant accepte parfaitement parce que
pour l'enfant n'y a pas de problème le
mot sexuelle tout coule moins naturel je
veux dire que la caméra passe par le
regard de l'enfant
ça c'est gênant parce que les sentiments
qui passe toujours par un enfant sont
ont tendance à nous émouvoir mais
intéressant de faire passer le film de
faire passer le même thème par le regard
par exemple du jeune amant du père on
est quand vous n'avez quand vous avez
quitté votre épouse
aux enfants avec l âge vous avez 5 et 6
ans mallet et ils ont vu ils ont connu
les noeuds le ou les garçons que j'ai
vécu et il n'y a jamais eu de problème
et j'ai même pas eu besoin de leur
expliquer dès qu on explique on fait un
problème d'ailleurs il faut prévenir
même l'explication montrer qu on
convient bien compte qu'on est heureux
des enfants sont eux-mêmes heureux de ça
ce qui ne supporte pas c'est le mensonge
et dans d'autres situations dans les
lutter même chose des convenants un
enfant qui découvre par hasard sur le
bracelet la de la montre alors là ça
peut être un choc parce qu'on lui cache
il en fait une montagne une chose
horrible mais si on est naturel les
enfants rien là il n'y a rien qui ne
puisse admettre et qu'il admet
volontiers il n'avait pas eu besoin
d'expliquer les choses sont seulement va
naturellement se voit pas et ce
personnage du film avait 14 ans est un
des usages délicat et il fait de fabiana
20 et elle est lorsque vos enfants
avaient 15 16 17 ans et c'est qu'ils
étaient avec d'autres d'autres camarades
de classe qui pouvaient se moquer de la
pédérastie ironisé et c'est en général
kiss avec leur père faisait partie des
homosexuels quelques haltes quelles
étaient leurs réactions
je ne sais pas mais je sais qu'une fois
dans après un débat comme ça comme ça
professeur de philo a parlé des bdl a
dit qu'on avait vu des pdl à la télé et
ma fille qui avait 10 septembre et avait
retrouvé au dimanche c'est mon père
faisait partie et c'est le prof qui
s'est écrasé je crois que quand les
enfants sont comme tous les ans les
élèves écoutent aujourd'hui même pas
quand on leur dit que quand on a fait
comprendre ça ils sont très forts ils
savent répondre eux-mêmes aux camarades
je suis il accepte par amour pour le
père peut-être non mais je crois qu'une
question de prendre le mot sexualité et
à problèmes d'adultes corrompu par une
pause par la société l'apprécient veut
dire en soi n'y a pas de problème c'est
qu'il ya des blancs des bruns et il ya
des gays et des p&t pas aidé street
il ya aucun problème c'est nous qui
avons fait problème c'est un siècle de
répression or soit le problème alors je
suis une françois de votre côté lorsque
vous avez lorsque vous avez quitté votre
époux ou vos enfants avec elle a eu
trois enfants 6 en trois ans et deux ans
et je suis tout à fait du même avis que
dominique fernandez vraiment ce film qui
est très chargé de malaise et de
morbidité est basé sur une absence de
parole c'est presque pire que de mentir
il ya une lourdeur tout au long de ce
film qui vient de qui vient de ce que
tout les petits s'ils ne sont jamais
éclaircies on laisse l'enfant s'enfoncer
dans le doute dans le questionnement
auquel personne ne répond et comme
l'enfant effectivement à 14 ans c'est
l'âge où on pose des questions
rationnellement
il est perdu parce que il a demandé il a
posé la question des bus vides a posé la
question le père a dit plus tard
l'emploi dit je pense que c'était
actuelle et me dira plus tard il n'y a
jamais de plus tard avec un enfant et
c'est vrai qu'un enfant
à 9 ans pose des questions pas tout à
fait dire est quand il est très jeune
lesquels sont détournés il faut toujours
répondre aussi entièrement de possibles
à ces questions mais je crois que quand
on quand on a un respect de la parole
c'est ce qu'ont fait naturellement on
n'a pas de théorie là-dessus on répond
d'ailleurs un enfant la candeur et la
franchise naturel de l'enfant engagent
la parole
enfin bon c'est comme ça j'avais
ressenti et je ne me suis même pas 10
vais-je me dire de ne pas lui dire j'ai
mouillé a jamais eu d'explication il y à
une onde explications au franc parler
non non vous n'avez pas dit je vis avec
une jeune femme jeudi phil hill et ils
l'ont découvert et sa belle-fille le
concept est il venait dans ma maison est
ici une fois très tôt qu'on m'a filé
avait à peu près trois ans ou quatre ans
elle elle m'a dit regardant avec cette
jeune femme avant que je quitte mon mari
et ma dîme et on dirait que tu l'aimais
et je me suis j'ai dit oui je laime mais
je me suis demandé d'où venaient une
prescience pareil un enfant de quatre
ans car jamais elle ne m'avait dit ça à
propos d'un ami ou d'une amie elle ne me
l'a dit qu'à ce moment là et j'ai trouvé
ça admirable la part d'un enfant est
actuellement g
juste si grand mère j'ai trois
petits-enfants et julia les n'est qu'à
sept ans pose des quantités de questions
comme ça à la frange et je réponds
toujours et pour lui marie clairet moi
nous sommes vraiment indissociables dans
ce cas qu'est-ce que vous qu'est ce que
vous dites succinctement qu'est ce que
vous expliquez un enfant je dis nous
habitons dans la même maison parce que
nous nous aimons et pour un enfant c'est
mais c'est beaucoup plus clair que pour
un adulte
l adulte quelquefois ne sais plus ce que
ça veut dire mais un enfant le sait même
s'il ne s'est rien à la sexualité
ils pressent ce qu'est l'amour je crois
et votre mari votre mari lorsque vous
l'avez quittée quelle quelle a été sa il
a appris votre votre homosexualité
oui je le lui dis vous savez il faut
savoir ce qu'on veut dans la vie on le
fait on n'atteint jamais ses buts sans
blesser à n'importe quel plan je crois
qu'on affiche de blessures aux autres je
crois qu'on ne peut pas traverser
l'existence aux infligé des blessures et
c'est vrai que c'est moi qui le lui dis
parce que je ne voulais pas qu'il y ait
de l'obscurité
je ne voulais pas partir pour de
mauvaises raisons j'avoue que ça a été
très dur pour lui parce qu'ils ne s'y
attendait pas du tout mais c'est
peut-être parce que nous étions
philosophe tous les deux peut-être ça a
été un peu à la chose
je crois tout de même que prêtre est
profondément
il a respecté cet amour que j'éprouvais
depuis bien avant notre mariage ce n'est
pas une rencontre que j'avais fait
après c'était un amour qui datait
d'avant j'avais donné ma parole
avant ce mariage était un mariage
inventé pour de mauvaises raisons
c'était un mariage le fabriquer vraiment
et ça ne peut pas tenir
alors évidemment je ne voudrais pas
avoir l'air d'avoir extorqué trois
enfants à un homme est de mettre des
robes et ensuite parce que quand je me
suis marié j'ai vraiment pensé que
c'était pour toujours je marquais que
c'était un mariage sans amour je le
savais mais c'était une façon tout à
fait
tournée de mettre un obstacle
incontournable entre cette femme et moi
et mais je ne sais si je ne pouvais pas
cessé de l'aimer et mon mari a très bien
compris que cette histoire antérieure
était si profonde que ce mariage devrait
casser cédé devant et je pense que nous
avions fait un mariage d'estimer que ça
restait une union destine
enfin je crois très profondément en tout
cas moi quand j'ai divorcé j'étais
absolument dans les mêmes sentiments que
pendant mes fiançailles
vous voyez c'est à dire que cet homme je
le voyais pour ceux qui l'étaient je
l'estimais pour ceux qui l'étaient je ne
pouvais pas l'aimer et ne pouvaient pas
m'aimer donc ça mais je veux revenir sur
ce que vous venez de dire l'instant on
vous avait dit je me suis marié je ne
suis pas mariée par amour c'était un
mariage un peu d'un peu de raisons pour
pour échapper à cette jeune femme
ah non c'est pas pour échapper c'est
pour mettre ces gens c'est ça notre vie
parce que jamais personne il se trouve
et c'est pour ça que j'ai le sentiment
très profond qui croît avec les années
que touchait osé toucher à la sexualité
ou à l'amour à la sexualité même de
quelques uns à ce monde la sexualité
c'est atteindre son être en profondeur
c'est c'est le détruire en quelques
sortes
et moi j'ai faillit être détruite par
cet homme qui était aumônier des
étudiants annoncent y à l'université qui
plus tard est devenu évêque de nevers et
qui m'a dit ça qu'il n'a pas avancé des
arguments religieux moreau qui m'a
simplement avancé le terrible arguments
contre nature sachant qu étant assez
droite est un philosophe jeu cet
argument lama précieux devrait
effectivement il m'a impressionné et
j'ai cru vraiment que j'ai cru vraiment
en ce moment là que persévérer dans cet
amour c'était perdre dieu mais on ne
peut pas cesser de vivre l'amour et on
ne peut pas perdre de vue non plus mais
ça je l' ai compris
au cours des années et c'était tellement
évident que ma véritable voir ma
véritable profondeur c'était de vivre
cet amour là que même si
des enfants j'avais confiance qu'on
pourrait trouver des acca mode des
accommodements avec la vie et j'ai
rejoint cette femme que j'aimais qui je
peux dire que je n'ai jamais cessé
d'aimer depuis depuis le printemps de 51
ça fait quand même longtemps est
vraiment en plus j'étais assez fasciné
par le fait de vivre l'amour et l'amour
pas l'amour d'habitude l'amour passion
de le vivre dans la durée ça c'était une
envie que j'avais parce que je trouve
que justement quand on quand on voir
l'homosexualité du des morts on ne pense
jamais il peut y avoir des passions et
durable aussi qu' on cite héloïse et
abélard tristan et iseult mais peut-être
qu'on pourrait mettre des prénoms
masculins ensemble et des prénoms
féminins ensemble est vraiment j'en
témoigne c'est possible c'est vrai alors
je crois qu'il est intéressant d'établir
le dialogue dont j'avais parlé de
valeurs il y a dix ans à peu près nous
avions fait une émission ici avec jean
louis borie avec yves navarre avec
angers peyrefitte et cette émission
avait été un événement parce que c'est
la première fois qu'on en parlait la
télévision dix ans ont passé
on va voir un petit peu et c'est le
coeur même du débat quelle est la place
que vous occupez les uns et les autres
agences entend les homosexuels qui sont
ici avec nous sud donc dans notre
société quels sont les rapports vous
avez avec vos enfants et vos parents
avec vos familiers avec vos amis etc
et là je crois qu'il est intéressant
d'entendre les opinions les sentiments
les expressions qui ont été formulés
asvp gilbert cannes
comme dans la première constatation
qu'on peut faire c'est que à la suite de
la vision de ce film l'enfant
incontestablement est le centre
d'intérêt les appels que nous recevons
ce soir aussi bien l'enfant qui est face
l'homosexualité de ses parents que celui
qui risque d'être comme certains le
disent avec effroi la proie du
prosélytisme homosexuels toutefois il
n'est pas question si vous le voulez
bien de donner aux très nombreux appels
dont nous sommes saisis ce soir sdp une
valeur de sondage mais il semble bien à
la différence de l'émission de 75 ans
vous parliez que l'homosexualité ne soit
plus vraiment aujourd'hui un sujet tabou
les téléspectateurs en parle semble-t-il
avec beaucoup plus de sérénité
il ne serait cependant pas tout à fait
honnête de passer sous silence les
appels vous vous en doutez bien qu'ils
expriment une indignation une colère je
vous donne quelques exemples cette
émission est scandaleuse elle sert à
cultiver le vice c'est une perversité il
est révoltant de faire passer pour du
raffinement ce qui n'est que des
cadences et bestial physiquement
d'autres eux parlent de malades y est
devise d'infirmité les plus hostiles
vont même jusqu'à déclarer c'est
outrancier mais il fallait le dire quand
même c'est dégoûtant ces gens là ne
méritent pas de vivre mais d'une manière
plus générale la plupart de ceux qui
montrent une certaine désapprobation à
l'égard des homosexuels le fond par
rapport à leurs enfants je vous le
disais en commençant trop d'exhibition
de publicité de prosélytisme également
faire croire aux jeunes que cette
éventualité tout à fait normale et très
graves si le nombre des homosexuels
augmente il n'y aura plus de sociétés
possible plus d'enfants et jouerait pour
terminer vous posez peut-être la
question qui est au noeud justement de
ce problème et elle nous vient d'un
garçon de 11 ans un petit parisien de 11
ans qui dit comment devient tôt
homosexuels si on le devient
est ce à la suite de certaines
fréquentations ou par opposition ou aux
parents ou alors cela vient-il de
naissance et une une jeune fille nous
pose presque la même question
l'homosexualité ne provient elle pas
d'un traumatisme psychique de l'enfance
et n'at-elle pas été accentuée par la
libération de la femme
devient tous répondent n'accepte plus
grands
je pense qu'on ne devient pas homosexuel
on accepte de l'être un jour peut-être
c'est peut-être là qu'il y a une
difficulté
la difficulté c'est d'accepter de se
nommer à partir d'un terme qui est
entendu de façon négative par la société
je pense que c'est ça tout à l'heure on
a beaucoup parlé à propos du film
des réactions de dominique fernandez et
de jocelyne françois était très très
juste
au niveau personnel mais je pense que
pour un petit garçon pour un petit
garçon avec ce qu'il ya dans l'ambiance
de référence masculine c'est à dire
c'était impératif quand lui impose
d'être nomme c'est à dire ça veut dire
d'aimer les femmes légal aimait les
femmes
je comprends je comprends très bien que
qu'un petit garçon soit profondément
troublé mais il est troublé il est
troublé la dans le film de deux manières
il est troublé parce qu'il est devant le
silence de quelqu'un qu'il est son père
et puis les troubles et aussi devant
quelque chose qui est très nouveau
peut-être dans sa conscience et qui peut
troubler tous les enfants hélas le seul
le seul crime commis s'il en a un c'est
justement ce silence
au niveau général non seulement au
niveau du père au niveau général en
fanfare il y avait une certaine
souffrance où france ô il avait en
france il se retrouve c'est quoi du coup
la sexualité c'est le sait le silence je
suis persuadé qu'un que si le
si l'enfant avait vécu avec son père
dans ce qu'apporte le quotidien de
banalisation et puis en même temps de
valorisation il aurait été certainement
moins mal à l'aise je moi je connais un
garçon qui dans des circonstances
particulières à élever son fils et je
dois dire qu'il y ait entre le père et
se hisse ce garçon qui a maintenant 16
ans des relations qui sont qui sont fort
belle et qu'on pourrait quelquefois
espérer des relations d'un cuisse avec
son père dans alors la question regarder
la question qui nous est posée qui est
une question évidemment extrême dans
l'instant cette image imagine très très
vaste et comment devient ton homosexuels
mais ce qui est intéressant je voudrais
revenir à jocelyne françois dominique
simonet c'est que tous les deux vous
étiez vous aviez des vous étiez
homosexuel avant de vous marier
oui bon c'est ce que vous m'avez dit
mais vous vous êtes bon vous ne savez
pas comment les hommes mariés de 12 ans
bon oui mais dans ma génération c'est à
dire avec quand j'étais jeune il ya
trente ans et ça c'est le grand progrès
que je veux que je me suis aujourd'hui
était impossible d'avoir une vie
homosexuelle normal bon c'est à dire qu'
il n'y avait pas de modèle homosexuels y
avait pas de télé du tout d'ailleurs mes
yeux pas de presse et pas de filmer pas
de livres on n'en parlait jamais j'ai
fait des études très longues j'ai fait
cai normal tout ça on ne parlait jamais
entre camarades étaient à bout même
s'ils n'habitent qui était comme moi
hein
on entend déjà mais c'était une chose le
fils je me suis censuré une fois qu'on
appelle au calme parce que je voulais
expliquer votre un personnage homosexuel
dans la matière je voudrais tout de
suite c'était en carrière soit disant
enfin où étaient les mythes enfin bon
c'était tabou et ce qui est plus grave
encore ce qui manque le plus c'est
qu'ils n'aient jamais de couples
homosexuels quelquefois deux femmes
s'étaient plus admis relativement les
deux garçons deux hommes qui vit
yves qui vit qui vivent ensemble ça
n'existait pas donc un jeune homme de 20
ans qui se découvre homosexuel
quelle vie s'offrait à lui ou bien la
vie sordide delà de la draille des
choses de kim qui me dégoûtait ou alors
la chasteté avant le mariage est têtu et
est une solution mais enfin je dis
chouette grosse parce que j'aimais
beaucoup ma femme aussi
je profite de l'occasion de dire que
l'aixois ne sont pas du tout misogyne
selon une fausse idée de nos sections
aime beaucoup les femmes enfin bon moi
j'aime beaucoup les femmes mes meilleurs
amis sont des femmes et les homosexuels
que je connais m aime beaucoup les
femmes furent si je voyais une
complicité entre ce qu'on repousse c'est
le modèle viril de tibhirine est donc le
mariage était une scission si on avait
la chance que moi d'aider mais sa femme
j'étais heureux longues années cette
femme et puis au bout d'un certain
nombre d'années elle elle savait que
vous étiez vous savez je n'ai pas été
correct avec elle on est vraiment une
vie pleine et puis a certainement sans
doute quelque chose était trop fort en
moi qui a fait éclater ce couple qui
décolle tu reposes est quand même sur
quelque chose qui n'était pas
complètement vrai même si la relation
était vrai il est une pas une composante
en moi je n'ai plus un homosexuel qui
est en fait ça et je me disais qu'on
peut expliquer ça justement je dis qu'à
12 ans moi je regardais les gravures de
statues grecques j'allais au louvre je
voyais les néoclassiques david giraud
des ça me touche et ça me bouleverse et
je savais pas ce que ça veut dire au 6
mai et ma sensibilité la sensualité été
orientés vers sap complètement
normalement et sans chichis sans son
traumatisme sans explication je crois
que dès qu'on veut explique
l'homosexualité au on est dans l'erreur
ou alors expliquons l'hétérosexualité
aussi je dis oui il ya les homosexuels
mais ce n'est pas ce qui allait en soit
ce n'est pas l'homosexualité
et oui ce qui n'est un jour c'est le
désir de l'assumer parce que comme les
ai tout à l'heure je suis françois il
est très important d'être heureux enfin
me l'avait pas dit comme ça mais c'était
très important d'accepter qu'ils ont la
grande ligne de saf de sa manière d'être
heureux et oui aux no camus moi
j'aimerais revenir si vous me permettez
sur vous tout à fait premiers mots les
trois premiers mots vous de les
prononcer avant avant avant le film
n'est ce pas et d'ailleurs on peut
revenir ensuite un enfant l'enfant du
film les premiers mots que vous avez
prononcé c'est le problème homosexuels
et je me pose nullement à vous les
jeunes a dit que c'est une expression
qui les ex pardonnez moi mais qui n'est
plus admissible c'est comme de parler du
problème juif c'est totalement
inadmissible
le problème ce n'est pas la judéité ce
n'est pas non plus l'homosexualité
l'homosexualité en soi n'est nullement
un problème le problème c'est ce qu'on a
appelé d'un mot qui est très malheureux
mais qui devra faire la faire encore ce
soir c'est l'homophobie c'est le racisme
anti e homosexuels la violence anti
homosexuel le mépris à l'égard des
homosexuels les difficultés de six toros
qui sanctionneront exalabs et la grande
habileté de ce film c'est que le racisme
anti homosexuels l'horreur de
l'homosexualité est exprimé même temps
par la parole mais par le regard d'un
enfant et comme le disait en revue comme
a recensé d'emblée sympathique et il
faut bien voir que les gens qui sont
légaux qui sont dans un racisme qui
manifeste un racisme ne sont pas
forcément antipathique
il ya des solutions qu'ils avaient des
antisémites charmant autant d'hitler de
vieille dame très gentille
c'était un problème de société c'est une
tare morale que ce soit l'antisémitisme
ou le racisme anti homosexuels c'est une
espèce de maladie dont il serait bon de
s'interroger
moi je rêve d'un dossier de l'écran où
on dirai comment devient ton homophobes
comment cette maladie
quelle est l'origine de cette maladie
est-ce que c'est contagieux est ce que
ce sont les mauvaises fréquentations les
mauvaises lectures
ça serait un débat très intéressant
pourquoi on ne parle jamais de sa coupe
à mon avis bien entendu la maladie dit
c'est le racisme anti homosexuels qui
s'abat sur ce malheureux malheureuse
enfant qu'il n'y peux rien je crois que
l'intérêt de l'intérêt du film c'est
tout de même de deux situés
l'homosexualité dans un milieu familial
qu'elles qui a été le vôtre qui a été
celui qui a été celui de ce qui est
nouveau et les gens qui ont qui sont nés
un jour qui ont une famille un père une
mère et mon général non mais ce qui est
nouveau c'est de montrer un cap art
c'est évidemment de montrer un cas
particulier on ne ne pense pas que c'est
intéressant de montrer ce cas
particulier d'un enfant qui découvre que
son livre est salée mais c'est la
manière dont ces traités la fin la fin
est un petit peu en errance qui nous
nous intéresse on n'est pas ici pour
pour qu'un ticket de la manière dont il
a été tourné dans ce qui est intéressant
c'est juste
vous aviez commencé à le dire en
critiquant mon propos du début je
comprends tout à fait mais je comprends
tout à fait les ghosts une bonne
réaction c'est intéressant vous dit il
n'y a pas de problème mais ce faisant on
vous dit
aya quand même à ce que les homosexuels
n'ont pas de problème je viens moi
sexualité en soi n'est pas attendu bien
entendu mais que j'aurais continué sur 7
sur cette lancée puisque ce qui nous
intéresse ce soir c'est de savoir le
noyage vous les observez justement très
souvent les gens sont j'ai parlé de
raciste récement les gens sont choqués
quand on compare la haine des
homosexuels à l'est derrière les
homosexuels un racisme
est-ce que vous avez le sentiment qu'il
ya eu il y a bien sûr il ya des
violences homosexuels justement ça
donnait entendu je me disais par la d1
tandis que disait jubilaire cannes on a
l'impression que le sujet parce qu'il ya
des il ya trois choses on peut parler de
racisme pour trois raisons à mon avis
parce que d'abord il ya eu les
déportations horrible et homosexuels ont
été les victimes du racisme raison d'une
façon très violent il y a le fait que
les homosexuels sont victimes de
violences physiques très nombreuses
beaucoup plus au fond que les juifs en
france aujourd'hui un autre pays où je
suis il ya dix ans par john il ya des
meurtres d'homosexuels dans l'est
partout en france y en a un exemple
c'est akalé non mais c'est sont
considérables et qu'est-ce que ça
deviendra journaux dans ce cas là c'est
encore un drame de leur sexualité
balma sexualité qui est il en cause ici
c'est une violence à leurs noms mais en
plus il ya une troisième phase on est là
nous revenons à la famille il ya c'est
pour ça qu'on peut parler de racisme et
peut-être c'est la raison pour laquelle
le racisme à l'égard des homosexuels est
plus dur que le racisme classique à la
proprement parler raciale
c'est que les
les jeunes juifs ou les jeunes noirs
jeunes arabes peu importe quand ils sont
l'objet d'un racisme ont tout de même
pour se protéger le premier groupe
humain à laquelle on appartient auquel
on appartient c'est à dire la famille
dans les scripts un jeune homosexuel
c'est beaucoup plus dur que ça puisque
le raciste très souvent vient de ce
qu'est le plus proche de ses parents ce
qui s'est passé avec vous peu importe
mon cas particulier est très doux loiron
de vous poser la question mais je vous
dirai ce qu'est ce que vous étiez en
province c'est plein vol est-ce que vous
avez comment ça s'est passé jeudi
qu'est-ce que ça ça peut se passer bien
ou mal je crois que c'est une question
d'amour ce qui ce qui est le plus grand
courage ce qui coûte le plus c'est de
faire de la peine à qui que ce soit et
jocelyne françois si on a besoin d'être
net reçoit même de vivre sa sexualité
qui est un grand bonheur en soit moi je
crois qu'il faut le dire l'homosexualité
ça peut être mairie face d'un grand
plaisir et il ya cette chose horrible
qui demandent je crois le plus grand
courage c'est qu'il faut quelquefois
faire beaucoup de peine à quelqu'un
jocelyne françois parler de son mari
elle a dit un jour il lui dire je
suppose non ce n'est pas ça ce n'est pas
le genre de vie que je veux avoir
d'autres doit faire de la peine à leurs
parents 2 d'autre doit faire de la peine
à des enfants comme c'est le cas à ce
qui est peut-être qu'il ya pire
hugo marçal oui je disais que même même
si la famille même si la famille a
suffisamment d'amour pour l'admettre il
est quand même très douloureux pour
l'enfant de sentir qu'à l'intérieur de
la famille il y a une peur et il y a une
peur il ya une peur des autres moi je
sais par exemple ma famille directe la
famille directe ad mon père ma mère mon
frère mais c'est enfin ma famille
directe m'a aimé même suffisamment pour
le comprendre pour m'accueillir
mais il faut un badge il faut un mur ils
font un mur avec les contres les autres
il me préserve contre les autres ils
sont donc mal à l'aise ils sont quand
même mal à l'aise et ça un enfant quand
j'étais très jeune ils le ressentent
rénale
j'aurais tenir sur une question sur le
hbo même homosexualité parce que dans
les bons celle
les missions de soins c'est qu'être gay
en 84 c'est très important ce qui est
sûr le monde parce que le mot homosexuel
c'est pour répondre aux spectateurs qui
parle de perversion vie c'est ça le mot
homosexuel et amant qui datent de 100
ans qui était créée par un écrivain
hongrois et maury blanc soit mot barbare
ce qui va préfixe grec au mot même et un
mot latin
donc c'est une injure déjà au langage
mais surtout celles ci sont contre le
sexe et beaucoup de gens de bonne foi
crois que les homosexuels ne sont
obsédés du sexe dont des pervers du
fétichiste où tout ça et ignorent que
les relations destine d'amitié d'amour
de communauté intellectuelle sont
exactement les mêmes entre j'entre deux
garçons entre du fiqh entre contre marie
est une femme est par exemple quand on
voit un homme et une femme ont dit sont
deux amants ou deux amoureux ou un
couple on dit jamais son 2 hétérosexuels
quand on voit deux gars au coude droit
de gironde y sont deux homosexuels là
une discrimination dans langage qui est
horrible je suis heureux que ce mot
tendent à disparaître
j'étais pas si moule le mot gay est le
meilleur en tout cas d'abord il plus de
plus gai soit vous américain tu rêves
que nous revenions d'ailleurs le plus
fréquemment possible à ce qu'ils m'ont
gardé ceux qui nous écoutent pour
connaître au fur et à mesure de tenir
vos propos la réaction gilbert vous
disais tout à l'heure en commençant qu'
il y avait peu d'appels qui réprouvent l
homosexualité or il semble que depuis le
que le débat s'est instauré beaucoup
d'appels nous proviennent de gens qui
disent bon très bien on peint des
réactions on parle d'un état de cette
dette a fait société se fait société
devient de plus en plus courant il est
rentré dans les moeurs
on est prêt à le recevoir très bien mais
il ne faudrait pas quand même banalisée
c'est un mot qui revient souvent dans
les apple banaliser l'homosexualité
comme la drogue d'autres disent je
trouve bizarre que l'on fasse tant de
publicité autour de l'homosexualité je
crois que c'était important à ce niveau
du débat de dire que les gens sont
aujourd'hui en croit un petit peu à une
interrogation
et puis je crois que le deal si vous
voulez le débat pourrait aussi
s'orienter comme le disait bien là
renaud camus tout à l'heure sur ce
racisme homosexuels je crois que le mot
est peut-être un petit peu fort mais il
semble bien qu il soit pas le même
ressenti la même manière à paris ou dans
les grandes villes qu'en province
il ya une homosexuelle de province qui
nous dit
l'homosexualité est dramatique dans ma
province je vis dans une angoisse
perpétuelle mêmes et je mène une double
vie
je voudrais le cacher à ma famille et à
mes amis d'autres d'autres disent
également je trouve regrettable qu'on ne
parle jamais des homosexuels de province
de las de l'aspect psychologique et
social que cela pose pour eux la
solitude surtout qui est la leur quand
le mot solitude revient aussi souvent
dans les appels il y a des difficultés
pour un nouveau sexuelle a trouvé un
emploi en province il ya beaucoup de
difficultés à trouver également des
logements
il ya un monsieur qui nous qui nous dit
je vis à 2 depuis cinq ans je suis
obligée de mentir pour éviter les
insultes aussi bien parmi les miens que
dans mon métier beaucoup de problèmes
face à la société
enfin vous voyez beaucoup d'alluré
lemieux genre qui semble dire que
la vie la vie n'est peut-être pas aussi
aussi rose que pour excusez moi du terme
mais les intellectuels qui se trouvent
sur leur plateau et qui semble vivre
très bien leur homosexualité
paul veyne d'abord je crois que ce qui a
beaucoup varié ce n'est pas le nombre
des homosexuels je crois pas qu'il
faille paniquer comme pour la diffusion
de la drogue ce qui a considérablement
varié c'est la censure et la nécessité
de se cacher selon les époques et quand
il ya nécessité de se cacher comme ça a
été encore le cas maintenant
encore que ça diminue beaucoup même dans
le village dans les villages comme je
les ai vus quand il ya nécessité de se
cacher il ya une quantité de souffrances
qu'il ne faut pas sous-estimer
c'est vraiment un grave problème social
non pas que l'homosexualité mais bien
que sa répression que sa censure par la
quantité de souffrances la craie je les
ai vues auprès de camarades que réélu
pendant 30 ans pendant mes études voir
dans tous les travaux que j'ai fait il
ya quelque chose là dessous qui est une
souffrance inutile et qui n'a aucune
espèce d'intérêt de la part de la part
des homosexuels en exerce sur eux ou un
exercée sur une espèce d'obligation
qu'on leur faisait de se taire ce qui
crée une quantité de souffrances
absolument inutiles et qui relèvent des
vieilles superstitions qu'on dit
médiévale c'est une tout c'est une
vieille histoire une souffrance qu'on
peut très facilement supprimés alors
supprimant la c sont si vous voulez de
par peur d'essayer censuré dr ce on
reste sur les quais sur les questions
qui doivent être progressives bon
d'abord il faut cette phrase elle peut
être évitée elle doit être évident et
très facilement
il est bien évident qu'à partir du
moment où un individu cherche à vivre
ressent lui quelque chose qui comme un
souffle qui doit le porter parce que
c'est sa nature parce que c'est comme ça
qu'il a envie de vivre si il fait il va
passer par le moulin moule familiale ou
un moule patriarcale où un moule la fin
group société
il est bien évident qu'il ya une
souffrance alors il faut savoir si la
société les sociétés modernes et
sociétés occidentales les autres
sociétés souhaitent effectivement faire
passer tous les individus par le même
moule ou si elle souhaite accepté
finalement de d'avoir avec eux des gens
qui n'ont qu'à le gnr parce que non ces
homosexuels
d'où vient-il
yann de la société n'est ce pas moi je
suis je suis moi-même aux homosexuels et
psychiatres et bien mes parents sont des
gens de la société ils m'ont mis au
monde j'ai grandi dans cette société il
aurait fallu bien évidemment comme tout
le monde que je sois éventuellement
hétérosexuels que j'ai des enfants je
pense que ça serait satisfait pas mal de
demandes
eh bien lorsque cette sexualité a été
connue je crois que mon père a été tout
à fait lettre m'a dit tu es heureux oui
c'est parfait et il ne m'a pas fait
passer par le moulin en ce moment il n'y
a pas eu là la souffrance qui est très
important parce que cette oppression
n'est ce pas que l'on vit en permanence
le pression que je fasse tout légendes
ayant ce n'est pas uniquement que les
homosexuels toutes les minorités qui ne
doivent pas exister comme elle existe
c'est un problème très important de
sociétés qui s'est toujours produit
depuis deux buts la société existe et je
pense que c'est un problème qui se
réglera peut-être un jour le jour où les
sociétés accepteront une part de
minorités différentes en leur sein qui
ne vont pas grandir c'est pas du tout la
dénatalité c'est pas du tout le fantasme
cette fantasque de mort terrible de la
part des gens de penser que parce qu'il
est homosexuel
la société veut disparaître en 75
monsieur mirguet disait si les
homosexuels la société disparaîtra parce
qu'il n'y aura plus d'enfants ça c'est
ça c'est l'angoissé de mort de monsieur
me régale à l'époque c'était et celle
angoisse de mort de nombreuses personnes
qui ne comprennent pas qu'ils le font
eux-mêmes angoissé par la mort et par
leur propre souvent homosexualité je
suis moi-même hétérosexuels comme on dit
et historien et par métier j'étudie de
sociétés dont on dit à juste titre le
plus grand bien qu'on admire soit parce
qu'elles ont réalisés dans tous les
domaines artistiques ou intellectuel
soit par leur puissance politique à
savoir la grèce et rome le chan ainsi
clairement c'est être sacré légionnaires
de sacrés soldats et puis qu'ils ont
couvert de tout le bassin méditerranéen
de leurs enfants
eh bien ces deux sociétés la grèce et
rome sont deux sociétés sans problème
homosexuel car l'homosexualité non
seulement nier a censuré mais le mot
même n'existe pas on ne change pas à
faire la distinction chez son chèque
dans ces deux sociétés
quand la coutume à juste raison de nous
présenter dans les études secondaires
comme de société exemplaire pour
l'occident l'homosexualité est carrément
admise que dis-je
elle n'est même pas perçu une formule
absolument courante en grec et en
pour dire qu'un homme fait l'amour un
homme fait l'amour on dit il à une femme
ou un garçon et c'est une façon de
parler en suède
or on dire un pacs de société
aujourd'hui vanté par tout le monde
depuis madame de romilly jusqu'aux
institutions et fut sacré ne sort pas de
son des sociétés faible ce furent aussi
des sociétés à homosexualité non
camoufler gilbert on se tourne un
instant vers vous pour savoir les
réactions qui vous parviennent aux
propos qui sont tenus bas et vous des
rues propres qu'il faut en revenir
quelques instants aux enfants parce que
vraiment c'est le sait le centre du
débat de ce soir semblé t-il et les
questions qui se posent sont les
suivants et je pense que certains nos
invités qui eux mêmes ont des enfants
ils vont pouvoir y répondre
cette personne nous pose de nice nous
pose cette question en raison du
mimétisme du fils envers le père le fils
d'un père homosexuel n'aurait-il pas
plus de tendance à devenir homosexuel
lui même où le père a peut-être
l'inciter à le devenir et une question
qui est qui se pose également pour une
fille c'est comment comment une mère
homosexuels voit-elle la possibilité à
sa fille de se marier un jour docteur ce
à propos de la l'incident du mimétisme
du mimétisme et coups de la citation je
pense que
il ya peu de chances que par mimétisme
il devienne lui-même homosexuel son père
est homosexuel s'il n'a pas en lui
simplement cette attirance sexuelle
particulière maintenant que ce fils
puisse un jour découvrir l'homosexualité
et qu'il découvre aussi
l'hétérosexualité puisque nous avons 7
bis potentialités en tout cas eh bien il
vivra son homosexualité ou son
hétérosexualité il y aura un moment où
il fera un choix peut-être n'en fera
t-il en pratique jamais d'ailleurs mais
il y à il ya un moment où effectivement
l'exclusivité hétérosexuels ou
l'exclusivité homosexuels par est une
erreur et je pense pas du tout que le
mimétisme d'un fils voyant son père où
la notation à l'exemple et c'est lorsque
j'y crois pas du tout josée lefrançois
j'ai personnellement je ne crois pas du
tout qu'il y ait une nature homosexuelle
ou hétérosexuelle je crois que tout est
une question de personne et de
rencontres la sexualité la vie affective
je crois ne s'éveille pas dans le vide
elle s'éveille elle s'éveille à propos
de quelqu'un et si ce quelqu'un est
suffisamment convaincant pour déclencher
tout ce monde qui colore rats vraiment
l'existence de la couleur lisons jaune
pour pour toute la vie c'est dingue ou
une couleur flamboyante et qui est celle
de la de la joie je crois que si c'est
une femme pour une femme et bien il se
trouvera que nous dira femmes
hétérosexuelles si c'est un homme pour
un homo dira qu'il est homosexuel et ça
peut être évidemment des hétérosexuels
et je proteste moi aussi comme denis
finlandaise et les autres contre
l'appellation et l'étiquette homosexuels
et hétérosexuels de même que je proteste
moi personnellement je suis la seule à
pouvoir le faire ici contre une
étiquette lesbienne parce que je trouve
que je ne suis jamais allé en grèce je
le regrette j'irai quand je pourrai je
n'ai jamais vu les ce buzz je ne lis pas
particulièrement c'est faux pour moi
c'est une politesse je ne vois pas
pourquoi je dirais que je suis lesbienne
c'est un bouquetin jolimont façade ne
recouvre pas du tout non
moi je dis simplement j'ai une femme et
c'est tout et je suis homosexuel parce
que parce que parce que c'est comme ça
mais j'aurais pu être hétérosexuel je
crois que je mourrais vraiment sans
savoir je suis homosexuel je ne crois
pas qu'il y ait une nature simplement
cette femme a été pour moi lettres
convaincant complètement et c'est tout
de même que je ne sais pas si je suis
fidèle parce que je n'ai jamais
rencontré quelqu'un de plus convaincant
qu'elle si je rencontrais quelqu'un plus
convaincant peut-être que je ne serai
pas fidèles donc on ne sait pas ces
choses là où je crois qu'on est pris
dans quelque chose auquel on adhère
et puis qu'on soutient par sa vie de
tous les jours mais à propos des enfants
vous avez dit je vais je vais être grand
mère où vous êtes quand même si je sais
quand on met un bourrelet les propos de
la question qui a été posée de
l'incitation ou d'exemplarité etc
qu'est ce que vous en pensez rien du
tout non il n'y a aucun mimétisme au cas
au contraire je vais vous montrer au
contraire quand les choses quand les
choses sont montrés le choix est fait le
choix je dirais je regarde quelque chose
et puis simplifiée quand j'étais enfant
moi quand j'étais enfant c'était tout à
l'heure le dominique fernandez disait
qu'il n'en avait aucune référence
valable et il explique être un mariage
un petit peu dans ce sens mais moi je
pense qu'il n'y avait pas de référence
va là par contre il y avait des
références atroce ça sentait la
monstruosité d'ailleurs on en parlait à
voix basse moi je me souviens de petites
histoires dans la vie jean et nous
vivions c'était des petites histoires
demandé c'était effrayant
c'était la monstruosité il vaut mieux
montrer les choses très calmement je
crois qu'à ce moment là le le jeune
garçon l'âge de la jeune fille enfin il
faut quand même faire confiance il faut
quand même imaginer qu'un jeune garçon
et une fille savent ce qu'ils font à ses
douleurs
bon je veux dire à vous entendre il n'y
a pas que je pourrais y en a deux
garçons et une jeune fille j'ai bien
compris que quelqu'un qui est si
quelqu'un avait 20 ans ce serait
intéressant de l'entendre dire qu'il
ressent aujourd'hui à 20 ans on aura
tout à l'heure par gilbert probablement
des témoignages de jeunes ont maintenant
on va lui demander on va lui demander
mais pas vous entendre les uns et les
autres vous défendez c'est assez normal
veut dire vous êtes plus conséquent
l'homosexualité est et on a un petit peu
l'impression
d'ailleurs c'est ce qui a été dit
attendez attendez c'est ce qui a été dit
tout à l'heure par un téléspectateur par
la voix de gilles
c'est qu'on a l'impression d'un certain
prosélytisme ne font pas du tout la
liberté de chacun d expliquer non non
non mes enfants je considère qu'on a
propriété je n'ai pas nier les a cités
mialy réfréner je voudrais les élevez
vous avoir élevé en sorte qu'ils se
sentent complètement libre qu'ils soient
homosexuels ou transsexuels c'est pas
mon affaire c'est la mer mais il ya
différents moyens d'empêcher la liberté
le procès du typhon et un mail à la
répression ou le leu leu nous coûter
cafard l'hypocrisie ya pire
je crois que l'éducation la bonne
éducation consiste à faire que à l
affaire que l'enfant à l'âge où il a des
choix importants à faire les fasse le
plus librement possible durée totale
d'un possible parce qu'on va beaucoup il
était intéressant qu'il ait plusieurs
références oui mais il s'agit juste
devancé ses boucles c'est beaucoup plus
intéressant d'avoir son entourage
j'ai pensé c'est loin et c'est la même
chose pour pour un enfant d'un qui vit
par exemple seul avec sa mère c'est
intéressant de voir autour de lui
d'autres enfants qui vivent seules avec
leur mère c'est intéressant de voir
facilement qu'il y à dd couple de
garçons qu'il ya des couples de femmes
ça existe d'alizée de ses enfants live
il voit beaucoup de choses ils sont
peut-être plus libre mais encore dire
c'est que moi je suis pas du tout
protégé par un système horrible qui est
horrible c'est bien aux religions que
quand sexualité ou en politique je suis
moi même et je souhaite que tout le
monde fasse des choix libres une face à
des choix par contre pierre choses plus
pour se défendre pour se cacher mais
soit libre moi je défends la liberté on
est proche où je crois beaucoup
d'homosexuels sont faso sur comme ça
voyons ce qu'on en pense de l'autre côté
déterminera ses dires svp gilbert si
vous voulez il ya maintenant un courant
qui se dégage c'est que contrairement à
ce que je vous disais tout à l'heure le
nombre d'appels qui au fur et à mesure
que des avances vous ai déjà une
première fois et qui n'est que
semble-t-il n'était pas contre
l'homosexualité semble se découvrir
maintenant on parle on revient à la
dégradation de la race à scandale pour
l'humanité y accéder mots qui reviennent
qui n'était pas au début de ce débat qui
n'était pas au moment du film
peut être était ce l'émotion soulevée
par ce film et il semble maintenant
qu'on a l'impression que le débat
s'oriente vers
puis-je aller entre entre guillemets
l'égalisation l'homosexualité c'est ce
que nous dit un certain nombre de
téléspectateurs la société et la société
aujourd'hui semble sont légalisés de
plus en plus l'homosexualité ils disent
qu on accepte maintenant on regarde
l'administration le concubinage
on va bientôt on va bientôt bénir
vis-à-vis de la religion va bénir les
vit en couple d'homosexuels hommes ou
femmes et il semble que cela pose
beaucoup de questions notamment sur des
problèmes de religion
les questions posées par un certain
nombre de téléspectateurs comment les
homosexuels se situe-t-il par rapport à
la religion et notamment par rapport à
la religion catholique
et puis également comment la religion
catholique accepte tel aujourd'hui ces
homosexuels alors que le pape semble
condamner l'homosexualité et l'a
condamnée si j'ai bonne mémoire louis
[Musique]
prix on ne cesse de poser la question
dans ce sens c'est à dire que
l'homosexualité est elle ou non accepter
par la religion mais moi je refuse
absolument cette perspective toujours
pour moi la ta morale absolue hissel qui
commence à se manifester peut-être dans
les questions ce qui est une tare de
société c'est le racisme anti
homosexuels nous nous ne revendiquons
aucun droit et si ce qu'il apprend que
je veux dire on ne demande pas on ne
demande pas être toléré on essaie de se
débarrasser de cette tare morale qui est
le mépris ou la violence à l'égard des
homosexuels
quant à l'église je trouve qu'une
question qui se pose est ce qu'on peut
contrôler jamais c'est de savoir s'ils
allaient ou non atteintes de ces racisme
anti homosexuels est ce que l'église et
est coupable escale à cette faute morale
qui me paraît une faute morale
épouvantable parce que ça va coûter des
vies humaines ça coûte et surtout une
quantité de mahler effroyable il ya des
gens qui sont épouvantablement
malheureux à cause de prêtres à cause de
l'église à cause de ses disques immacula
de j'espère évidemment se justifier de
cette quantité immense de malheur à mon
avis non seulement totalement inutile
mais en plus criminel est ce que elle
elle peut se justifier
moi je trouve que les homosexuels dans
avoirs doivent en avoir assez ne se pose
est constamment en
en personne qui plaide pour quelque
chose il faut renverser la question il
n'y a pas de problème sexuel le problème
c'est la répression au tuyau sexuels
dans l'église est très gravement
coupable pas toutes les époques
d'ailleurs signalé cette impression
aujourd'hui en 84 en france par exemple
on jouait souvent elle essaie de
rattraper le train en marche vous savez
je reste disaient les l'église s'est
rendu compte que prolétariat était
intéressant au moment où elle a pensé
qu'il allait faire un gros héritage
maintenant aussi le glisse peut-être
essayer de récupérer les homosexuels on
leur dit peut-être elle va tenter ce
couleurs mais c'est elle qui a des
comptes à rendre tout le malheur qu'elle
a causés aujourd'hui encore dans les
provinces françaises et pas seulement
dans les provinces à paris c'est fou le
nombre de gens qui sont en règlement
malheureux qui sent qu'ils sont qui se
suit 6 mai mais un autre mais celui-ci
est donc dont l'église espère mais deux
homosexuels et bien su épauler ses
précieuses révélations religieuse
pourquoi parce que comme
parce que j'existe donc unique une image
absolument révoltant de l'homosexualité
personne ne veut être ça l'image type
qu'on voit dans les médias dans les
journaux dans les conversations surtout
les propos des gens au développement
sexuel c'est une chose que personne ne
veut être moi quand j'avais 14 ans quand
je voyais l'image d'un nouveau sexuelle
et c'était la pire des ora c'était la
dernière chose que je voulais être
écouté ça les choses des choses ont
beaucoup évolué ne serait ce ne serait
ce que ne serait-ce que c'était mission
de ce soir vous apparaissez re direct si
clairement exprimé un certain courage
depuis des années c'est pas cette place
aussi tout le monde à paris ouverte à
des gens comme nous je m'y reconnais
c'est l'europe le centre est un peu
qu'on n'a même pas de problème à
regarder catégorie il ya des faits la
théorie des gens comme nous je pense que
vous faites données prélevées on est des
privilégiés ont été prises à dire qu'on
est capable on est capable de regarder
notre vie et avec un peu de courage et
un peu de patience on est capable aussi
de l'assumer ou daphné je comprends très
bien je comprends très bien qu'un
homosexuel par exemple je prends
l'exemple d'un jeune garçon qui n'a pas
de qui n'est pas d'une très grande
culture ou même qui était plus fragile
qu'il est besoin que l'église lui dise
oui c'est en ce sens qu'il est criminel
bien sûr si on fait appel à eux
attendent et nous n'avons pas à faire
une belle à l attendait dépassons enfin
les sondes malheureusement nous n'avons
pas d'ecclésiastiques ici ce soir pour
répondre à cela et puis on a constaté
mais mais hugo marsan vous êtes
journaliste
vous avez d'ailleurs publié un livre qui
est une
recueil des enquêtes et des reportages
que vous avez fait bon et tellement une
question c'est vrai que l'on n'a pas
répondu à une question à laquelle on n'a
pas répondu c est vous venez de le dire
vous venez de reconnaître très très
loyalement que vous étiez des
privilégiés vous viviez à paris vous
avez des métiers vous êtes romancier etc
vous est pris mais suite à l'éruption
reste en vie tout en province esquissé
ce qui a été demandé tout à l'heure et
on a eu je crois qu'on y vit assez mal
tout dépend évidemment province ou dans
des petites villes ou les houles et où
les choses sont plus évidentes cd -
jailli dans les granges et les en
général en général le garçon ou là je ne
sais pas pour les jeunes fij danse est
peut-être un peu différent mais le
garçon qui véritablement un jour veut
pleinement vivre son homosexualité en
général
il vient à paris où il va dans une
grande ville il va dans une grande ville
parce que c'est un problème de nombre
tout simplement c'est un problème de
nombre c'est à dire c'est qu'il est sous
le regard de dire que je veux dire un
jeune exercer un métier dans une petite
ville on est continuellement sous le
regard c'est souvent le voyez par
exemple qu'il est plus difficile un
homosexuel de postuler pour un emploi
il risque de se voir refuser oui et je
sais que par le par le journal cube je
travaille je sais que souvent nous avons
des lettres ou des garçons ils disent
on m'a refusé cet emploi uniquement
parce qu'on sait que je suis homosexuel
oui ça arrive très couramment c'est très
courant très comment moi je crois que si
les homosexuels en général ne laisser
passer aucun détails de la vie
quotidienne par exemple aller à la
banque et de vente est si l'on vit un
compte commun règle les problèmes
d'assurance répondent par par des auc
est concrètement avec san fermo je ne
parle pas d'exhibitionnisme et répondre
vraiment et fasse état de leur état et
c'est tous massivement à j 7 à 6 je
crois que la société serait obligé de
les considérer à part d'une façon qui
soit à part entière seulement toujours
où il ya cette peur c'est la menace de
souffrance qui engendrait mais toujours
ya cette paire qui engendre cette
dissimulation
mais c'est extrêmement dommage et moi je
crois que dominique je sais que comme en
province ou dans les milieux sont pas
une monnaie virtuelle c'est très
difficile mais aussi beaucoup
d'homosexuels qui ceux qui s'auto
punissent we go qui manque simplement de
courage
aujourd'hui je crois qu'en france un
régime libéral même les lois
discriminatoires ota bolides ont été
volés par le régime socialiste et donc
il n'y a plus de deux mois c'est la
pression des siècles qui fait que
l'homosexuel n'ose pas y changer quoi
pouvait affirmer aussi un autre système
politique pouvait le dire c'était très
impressionnant
on est un petit peu surpris en france
audard vous lisez dans un régime tout à
fait libérale
ah oui un certain nombre de choses non
mais t'as fait bonjour je prends à quai
et notes mais on s'aperçoit que vous
et pardonnez moi le mans qui va
probablement faire sursauter vous vivez
un peu en ghetto maintenant je savais
bien que vous avez vous abordé le lieu
de rencontres auxquelles vous parlez
dans votre vie mais n'ont d'abord pas du
tout j'ai embrayé invocations trouve que
certains moments on est content de se
retrouver ensemble les hétéros aussi
mais qui sont ces tournages
quand j'arrive oignons c'est une image
un peu caricatural cause homosexuelle
vendant des joailliers volontairement
une image caricaturale curie et roddick
est un petit peu ce que les choses sont
si vous le décrivez c'est la naissance
mais c'est une minorité ce sens dès ma
naissance attendez attendez attendez à
tous à la fois vous vous décrivez dans
votre livre par exemple dans les
chroniques à kriens certain nombre de
réunions d'homosexuels qui se retrouvent
dans des lieux de rencontre et ses bras
qui comme il ya des boîtes hétérosexuels
il ya des quartiers où il ya un tas de
boîtes hétérosexuels on parlera alors du
ghetto hétérosexuels de pigalle ou de
matignon l'une ses jambes ou la foire de
la chair mais est-ce que je peux revenir
sur cette question dès des privilèges
qui ont peu parlé tout à l'heure
certainement et on disait que nous
avions le grand privilège c'est vrai
mais tout ne pas oublier qu'il ya eu un
moment où il a fallu être très crois je
prendrai une décision
et toutes ont parlé de la nécessité de
se cacher et c'est vrai qu'elle existe
mais je vois que c'est un cercle vicieux
tv line parce que la société
hétérosexuels majoritaire forces plus ou
moins les gens à se cacher mais une fois
qu'elle se cache il dit c'est bien qu'il
doit y avoir quelque chose cachée
puisqu'il se cache alors là on est pris
on est pris dans un jeu terrible dont on
ne peut sortir que par un acte de
courage qu'il faudra que tout le monde
prenne un moment ou un autre c'est à
dire de prendre la décision de sortir au
grand jour et ce n'est pas de
l'exhibitionnisme
ça aussi c'est un terme qui faut relever
les basques ont pas de l'exhibitionnisme
homosexuel on en parle c'est un peu
comme si on parlait les peuples
coloniaux les peuples colonisateurs
pardon si le peuple coloniale se met à
parler dans sa langue dit mais c'est
inadmissible c'est de la provocation
et si nous nous sommes tout simplement
nous même si nous
on comme nous sommes la société
hétérosexuels majoritaire dit mais c'est
de la provocation à notre endroit
et si on se montre trop grand chose tout
simplement pas du tout par le moindre
prosélytisme seulement pour être nous
mêmes sans se cacher ils disent mais
c'est du prosélytisme
elle essayait de l'exhibitionnisme il
faut se méfier de ce terme
exhibitionniste juste un instant nous
faisons une nouvelle incursion asvp
gilbert calmes
oui une question une question qui vient
d'arriver c'est un téléspectateur nous
dit très souvent en tout cas ce qu'on
peut voir des homosexuels qui qui nous
côtoient que l'on voit dans la rue ou
dans les temps dans les maisons qu'on
peut fréquenter les homosexuels deux
sortes ou suivent avec des jeunes gens
souvent beaucoup plus jeune que et la
question disposer de savoir qui s'il
peut y avoir entre deux hommes deux
femmes une relation durable en toi des
êtres qui ont 13 ou 15 ans ou 20 ans de
différence d'âge
fiat a des pas très importants parce que
je trouve qu'ils méritent dans
l'homosexualité c'est que on passe
certaines barrières qui sont qui sont
des marques des barrières retrouve plus
souvent dans le certaines limites
contournant le mariage c'est bon mariage
c'est souvent de deux deux personnes du
même âge souvent les mêmes positions
sociales longtemps été comme ça et il ya
déjà de ces conscrits l'homosexualité
c'est c'est le désir qui se manifestent
librement c'est l'amour qui se
manifestent librement sans considération
sociale ni matériel souvent puisque
c'est à l'amour qui n'est même pas
reconnue donc d'un humour qui plus
difficile et plus précaires aussi et
donc il ya la liberté a fini toutes les
possibilités qui joue d'âge très
différent de conditions sociales très
différentes qui est fréquent aussi et on
voit l'amour à l'état libre se
manifestent beaucoup plus souvent si je
peux pas le dire que ce procès vis mais
non je crois que l'amour se manifeste
plus souvent état pur dans le mot
sexuelle dans l'armée où il n'ya pas
débuter sociaux il n'y a pas assez pas
appuyer s'est pas reconnue par société
il n'y a pas
il n'y a pas de patrimoine comme maya
pas d'héritage n'y a pas de belle
famille il n'y a pas tout ce qui cimente
un mariage et pas d'enfants mais entendu
donc c'est l'amour à l'état pur et
l'amour c'est l'amour n'a pas de l'apa
limite quelque vingt ans peut aimer
quelqu'un de de 50 ans
quelqu'un de riche ptb quelqu'un d'une
autre audition sociale et c'est ça qui
est merveilleux c'est qu'il ya pas du
tout c'est qu'on n'est pas
conditionnelle on aime parce que c'est
la personne ce sont deux personnes qui
se rencontrent donc pensé ni à l'âge de
la commission sociale ni association
fortune et ça c'est très cette chose qui
peut être très belle et qui souvent très
belle dans l'homosexualité
oui c'est une des raisons de plus de la
répression aussi l'homosexualité senti
comme le comble de l'amour libre de
l'amour non institutionnelle donc
quelque chose d'inquiétant et pour
beaucoup de gens oui j'avais une amende
de gens mariés qu'ils sont homosexuels
effrayant sas avait aidé au pouvoir
willocq qui a réussi à être libre c'est
pas tolérable c'est pour ça que racine
de l'europhobie donc pas rallié c'est
bien si bien le spectacle la liberté
d'autrui qui est intolérable pour
quelqu'un qui n'a pas eu ce courage
comme ça j'en l'église a toujours à
toujours puni la sexualité en
l'assortissant du mariage et authentifié
par là vous êtes vous avez survolé très
vite un problème important qui est celui
des enfants veut dire que le fait de
vivre
ensemble ou femme dont ses terres a
interdit d'avoir des enfants
par nature et est ce que c'est un est ce
que c'est un certain manque est ce qu'il
ya un certain nombre de d'homosexuels
qui souhaitent par exemple adopter des
enfants ou s'occuper d'enfants est ce
que est ce qu'on ne peut pas expliquer
aussi là est-ce qu'on peut pas répondre
à la question qui a été posée tout à
l'heure de savoir pourquoi certains
vivent avec des garçons plus jeunes
parce qu'ils ont un peu l'impression de
haoud être le remède quelque chose est
ce que ce mot homosexuel qui est
tellement cat ikea touche à tout de même
me semble-t-il un avantage étymologique
ça veut dire le désir sexuel pour le
même et si je peux donner mon cas
particulier
je suis va voir demain sexuelle au sens
pur c'est à dire je suis pas du tout
pédéraste les pages et pas de désir pour
les mères n'ont pas à s'inquiéter moi je
ne m'intéresse pas à voler ni aux
enfants ni les adolescents et c'est une
homosexualité qui est le désir du
semblable rencontré quelqu'un qui a le
même âge que moi il ya une différence de
20 tours dans un sens ou dans l'autre
c'est pas ça et je vois que ça pose une
question plus large c'est que on
s'interroge beaucoup sur la nature de
l'homosexualité et je crois que c'est
une question qui n'a pas beaucoup
d'intérêt parce que d'abord on ne
trouvera jamais la raison est le vrai
qu'il est plus plus intéressant de
s'interroger sur son histoire d'autre
part et sur sa géographie et parce qu'il
ya des formes d'homosexualité qui sont
très nombreuses quand on parle de la
grèce antique on parle tout de même
assez largement
je simplifie vraiment exagérément le
professeur van cau les gens avaient de
pédéraste du sud alors eu il ya
aujourd'hui une homosexualité qui est
qu'on pourrait appeler très
grossièrement américaine par exemple qui
n'est pas du tout ça qui n'est pas [ __ ]
rationnelle je n'ai rien contre les
pédérastes au sens strict c'est à dire
contre les gens qui désirent n'étant des
adolescents mais moi ça ne me concerne
pas ce n'est pas du tout mon
homosexualité je crois qu'il faut pas
par la nature une sexualité qui a peu
d'intérêt ce qui est intéressant c'est
d'en parler d'un point de vue historique
et géographique de voir que elle n'est
pas la même dans tel pays et nantes à
lauzach elle n'est pas la même
à telle époque oui ça beaucoup varié
mais aussi les modes l'homosexualité a
musical dont un à mi mots récemment me
parlait très souvent paraît être une
mode qui a d'ailleurs beaucoup varié
d'année en année je ne dis pas dans sa
diffusion mais dans les formes qu'elle
prenait et laisser voir si la défensive
de viacom des tentatives au sein de la
liberté de créer des styles de créer des
façons d'être des façons considéré comme
plus justes comme meilleur il ya des
tentatives dans tous les sens et c'est
ce qui donne la diversité dans le monde
mais je crois que le maximum de la
diversité des différentes formes
d'homosexualité vient surtout des degrés
et des formes très différent de la
censure c'est lille à des pays où
l'homosexualité peut réprimer ou bien
certaines formes par exemple la
passivité seulement sont blâmés et c'est
surtout des différences de censure qui
font les différence d'apparence de
l'homosexualité ne semble en tout cas à
travers les siècles c'est très sensible
nouveau marché la bonne heure plusieurs
les textes il est exact que les figures
de rencontre à l'intérieur de nos
sexualités sont riches les figures sont
riches ne serait-ce que pas seulement le
plan de l'âge est par exemple de la
relation sociale était donc on peut pas
imaginer qu'on imagine mal dans une
relation hétérosexuelle et surtout à
l'intérieur du mariage le les variations
de rencontres et d enrichissement que
réciproque que ça peut donner ça c'est
une chose vous n'avez qu'à moutinot
rayonnait ce 15 août on est passé très
vite sur quelque chose sur peut-être le
désir de paternité de l'homosexuel je ne
vois pas peut-être peut-être que le
colombo sexuelle peut avoir une un désir
de paternité
moi je ne
je dirais que dans mon cas particulier
il est exact aujourd'hui dans ma
relation homosexuelle il y as
certainement une composante de cet ordre
puisque j'aime quelqu'un de beaucoup
plus jeune que moi et que c'est une
chose de très enrichissante et que je
crois que je que c'est une manière pour
moi de peut-être d'être d'être paternel
peut-être je ne sais pas non il faut se
méfier aussi parce que quand les je
pense qu'il faut se méfier à l'intérieur
de chez les homosexuels quand des
homosexuels font appel à des demandes du
genre mariage possibilité d'avoir des
enfants et cetera il faut savoir faire
la part des choses
très souvent ces demandes elles sont
quelquefois sincère mais parfois elles
disent autre chose
le10 cette société nous refuse si elle
nous octroyait ces choses qui sont par
définition qui appartiennent par
définition à l'hétérosexualité ça
voudrait dire qu on nous reconnaît
je reviens à la fragilité de certains
êtres je reviens à la difficulté qu'ont
certains êtres à s'assumer je reviendrai
tracé cité de renaud camus qu'il ya un
manque de courage et certains ou une
impossibilité de le faire dans la
solitude donc à travers ses idées
mariage reconnaissance du concubinage
etc tous ces choses est entre très
bonnes en même temps elle cache le fait
qu'un homosexuel demande à la société
tel qu'il est c'est à dire à majorité à
grande majorité des ro sexuelle de le
reconnaître
à l'intérieur de ce système svp une
question au docteur seuls les
homosexuels nous dit un commerçant peul
marron été pendant longtemps considérés
comme des désaxés sexuellement et même
l'om est ce fut un temps et c'est la
question qui est posée est ce que ça
existe encore aujourd'hui l'om est
mondiale de la santé à considérer
l'homosexualité comme un fléau social au
même titre que l'alcoolisme par exemple
enfin c'est pas le web ainsi
considéraient l'homosexualité comme un
fléau social ça c'est autre chose non
l'om est c'est la classification
aujourd'hui encore de l' oms
et c'est homosexualité ses attirances
sexuelles prédominante ou exclusive pour
un être du même sexe avec ou sans
rapport avec ou sans un rapport physique
les à l'homosexualité
avec ou sans rapport physique la
définition actuelle de l'om sc avec ou
sans rapport physique et une sexualité
ce rapport physique
je voudrais je vous donne un défi mais
je vais y revenir parce qu'il ya
d'autres définitions maintenant que plus
intéressante à mon avis deuxièmement la
deuxième phrase dans la définition de
l'om mais c'est que le finalement pour
considérer que le que l'homosexualité
soit une maladie mentale est un
phénomène très contreversé alors l'om
est dans l'adn fictivement 7e ne se
mouille pas puisque finalement ne
tranche pas le problème par contre les
américains qui ont fait une autre
classification qu'on leur connaît qui
s'appelle le dsm dsm qui la
classification des maladies mentales aux
états unis qui a été traduit en france a
d'ailleur vos efforts s'appelle le dsm
iii 3e classification ne considère plus
l'homosexualité comme une maladie
mentale et je crois que une bonne
personne tant par à tout à l'heure je
crois qu'actuellement ce que les gays
demande c'est effectivement que l
organisation mondiale de la santé
veuille bien mettre au point ce problème
de définition et je pense que je le
pense qu'en tant que moi personnellement
et en tant que petit tient je pense que
on est infirme aujourd'hui je pense
qu'on est très infirme si on n'est pas
capable de reconnaître en soit même si
on n'est pas homosexuel sur les pasdaran
de reconnaître qu'on a une homosexualité
même si on est le meilleur hétérosexuels
le français au début au début de
l'émission qu'il ya effectivement des
questions qui sont venus la part des
téléspectateurs peu au début
gilbert kahn a dit en dix ans certains
considèrent la gd j'avais noté la
sexualité comme une maladie
d'autres comme un avis et d'autres
encore comme une infirmité ce n'était
pas une année pas une perversion
ce n'est pas une maladie mentale
la plupart des gens effectivement qu'ils
pensent à ce trou par rapport à la
société dans laquelle ils vivent
aujourd'hui
sont débranchés si j'ose dire que
gilbert cannes au docteur surf toujours
et après ce qu'il vient de nous dire que
pense-t-il de ce propos d'un antiquaire
de paris qui nous dit j'ai vécu vingt
ans avec un garçon aujourd'hui je vis
avec une femme dont j'ai un enfant je
voudrais savoir s'il ya une possibilité
de rechute et sur le mont rushmore
attirer votre attention
je crois que la question est posée parce
qu'elle elle probablement ce monsieur
doit doit doit souffrir d'éventuellement
abondé cette femme qu'il aime peut-être
peut-être qu'il a choisi parce que pour
enfin faire comme tout le monde nous
pour avoir un enfant
peut-être en fait son désir c'était
d'avoir un enfant je pense que si cette
femme lui a donné un enfant s'il l'a
aimée suffisamment pour qu'elle lui
donne cet enfant et si il l'aimera
toujours cette femme elle sera la mère
de son enfant
maintenant qu'il est une rechute je
pense que s'il a vécu pendant plusieurs
années avec un homme et si aujourd'hui
il retrouve la possibilité et le souhait
drone de continuer à vivre avec un autre
homme
ou peut-être même le même eh bien je
pense qu'il faut qu'il le fasse bien sûr
enfin bon je veux dire chut chut c'est
peut-être parce que ce monsieur aussi
une vitre est censuré ou qui s'est
laissée censuré beaucoup dans sa vie le
soin que ce n'est pas une rechute peut
dire aussi les skippers semaine françois
perpétuelle d'étonnement c'est pas du
tout qu'il y ait des hétérosexuels ou
des homosexuels c'est qu'il y ait si peu
d'âme en si peu d'amoureux dans le monde
je trouve qu'il ya très peu de gens qui
qui mêle comme valeur première de leur
existence qui valait amoureuse ils
s'intéressent beaucoup à l'argent à leur
travail à toutes sortes de choses à
l'argent beaucoup
au profit bon au jeu mais il ya très peu
de gens qui pensent qu'ils semblent
vivre selon le critt selon un critère
qui serait prédominant et qui serait
l'amour j'ai trop qu'un peu d'allemand
moi je rencontre très bonne et je suis
très content d'entendre ça parce que je
pense réellement que l'homosexualité
aujourd'hui femmes dans leurs mosquées
disons c'est ces gens qui se permettent
de vivre une sexualité qui n'est pas
tout de même la sexualité tout le monde
et qui ne font pas comme tout le monde
jean c'est très important parce que on
l'a bien vu en tout cas quand on reprend
l'histoire un petit peu comment la judéo
chrétienne t est venu s'installer après
les grecs comment pour des raisons
économiques patriarcale il a fallu
installer un système économique qui
fonctionne on a des enfants on puisse
avoir une une procréation importante etc
on a bien vu comment tout ça s'est
installée on l'a bien vu comment ça
fonctionne et puis ensuite ça s'est un
petit peu relâché pendant la révolution
on a on a donné l'accord pour leur
sexualité tout le monde pouvait être
moins cruel sans que ça pose de problème
puis ensuite il ya eu un rôle tout puis
on est venu à vichy en 42 ou le 6 août
finalement 42 on a décrété leur
sexualité
je pète un voulait effectivement nous
préserver de notre malheur et il a fait
déporter en donnant les cartes et non
des homosexuels français il a envoyé se
faire tuer dans les camps de
concentration avec les juifs et les
toiles rose et aujourd'hui on arrive à
une société où on continue à constater
que finalement les homosexuels sont des
gens qui effectivement privilégie
l'amour privilégie le système d'amour
aux dépens d'un système qui est un
système économique aujourd'hui dans le
système hétérosexuels si l'audition
devait l'opposer c'est a priori le
l'argent qui prime
et puis c'est une affirmation me semble
qu'il a tout gratuit on va y avoir des
gens quand même qu'ils se marient pas
ramenant je m'imagine dans le monde mais
c'est le gain des nombreuses années
depuis dix ans bien évidemment par
exemple depuis dix ans mardi
je crois tout ça a beaucoup évolué et
qu'aujourd'hui dans beaucoup d'autres
les milieux bourgeois et milieux
ouvriers des meilleurs et bien tout ça a
beaucoup évolué et on rencontre des gens
aujourd'hui qu'ils sont plus contre
l'homosexualité et qui vous disent les
hommes politiques qui aujourd'hui se
servent de l'épouvantail homosexuels on
ne peut pas les suivre non ça ne vaut
pas la peine
on oublie que la répression la grande
répression datent du 19e siècle de
l'essor de la bourgeoisie industrielle
commerciale ou xviiie siècle où le
viième siècle les moeurs était
infiniment plus libres d'eygalières
casanova ou tallemant des réaux et la
répression l'origine n'est plus
maintenant militaire chez les hébreux
autrefois ou religieuse et économique
il fallait que les femmes fassent des
enfants et qu'on produise que consomme
et ce système allait avec
l'hétérosexualité et la procréation et
sa durée pressante au falsetto 18ème
siècle et ça a mené à cette effroyable
répression qui a un peu éclaté avec
freud d'un produit dans bourgeoisie
entre 1900 et maintenant au sort un peu
de ça et on redécouvre le l'ordre ou le
désordre amoureux et ça c'est très
important je peux te dire que dans lyon
le système entre guillemets homosexuels
l'amour est plus beaucoup plus grande
place pas toujours à je pas dit que tous
les homosexuels du grand public un peu
idyllique sans jugement je vais dire que
si on ait pu rappeler situation l'amour
qui transperce les barrières
transgressent les lois se retrouvent
plus souvent plus souvent jeudi chez les
homosexuels parce qu'ils sont
indifférents à l'ordre économique alors
matériel à l'ordre à tout ça et son
essai la plus la folie souvent quand
même leur situation comme beaucoup plus
précaire il n'ya pas d'été et si l'amour
16 par exemple c'est une catastrophe
mais entre mari et femme si l'amour
cesse dans beaucoup de cas s'est sauvé
parce qu'elle est enfin et patrimoine
tout ça très souvent il ya des tas de
mariage kitty qui sont finies du de gens
qui ont pourri que doré qui continue
jusqu'à la mort qui semaient entre les
comptes sont les homosexuels 16 c mais
quand le courant du désir c'est sa
catastrophe
jacobs et valises ont par trop goûté
c'est le drame c'est la solitude absolue
dont il est autant de
ibro sexuelle jusqu'au qui oppose c'est
plutôt mariage auquel amoureux on sait
que tu veux mais il me semble qu'il ya
une plus forte ça fait très touché parce
qu'on avait dit m forte d'une forte dose
de circulation électricité d'amour
beaucoup plus important dans le rapport
sexuel a percé avant l'amour iranien
voilà gilbert ont fait une incursion je
vais peut être pas perdre nos amis et
puis bon on en vient à vous tout de
suite gilles berkaoui sur sur
l'apparence des homosexuels beaucoup de
questions sur c'est pourquoi les
homosexuels masculins ont-ils souvent si
souvent un visage d'apparence féminine
est-ce une réalité physique il bien cela
correspond-t-il un besoin psychologique
de ressembler au sexe féminin est il
nécessaire un homosexuel de prendre une
façon spéciale de parler ou de
s'accoutrer ou de s'habiller ou de se
présenter de se déplacer et la question
bien sûr qui est posée c'est de savoir
si nos invités de ce soir se sentent
proches de ce qu'on peut qu'on peut être
considéré dans certains milieux comme
une caricature de l'homosexualité
alors paul vanilla d'apparence typique
d'un homosexuel chauffe chez deux rares
individus qui par jeu ou par folie ou
parce qu'on veut en remettent je vais
vous donner un témoignage
il se trouve qu'il ya quatre ans j'ai co
présidé avec michel foucault la science
inaugurale du congrès homosexuels arkadi
on sera sûr j'étais là en tant que
témoin hétérosexuels j'ai eu devant moi
700 personnes 700 hétérosexuels dont
deux hommes politiques dont un sénateur
qui pour la première fois décrypté ce
qu'ils étaient j'avais devant moi une
foule de 700 personnes de français
moyens si j'ose dire parfaitement normal
et si j'avais rencontré le n'importe
lequel entrent dans la rue j'aurais été
incapable de dire celui-là c'est un homo
c'est une légende c'est un mythe à peu
près celui comme celui des juifs ou lu
ceci vraiment de chez marras si ceux ci
font des homosexuels vous ne le
connaissez pas je ne vais pas tout à
fait d'accord je dire je pense qu'il est
très important je pense qu'il est très
important
et là et je souhaite c'est très
important que certains certaines
personnes découvrent leur sexualité
puisse parce que il la découvre et parce
que peut-être que
c'est peut-être l'image d'une femme
qu'il préfère représenter ou peut-être
c'est l'image c'est peut-être l'image
d'un dur d'un homme dur violent viril
qu'il préfère représenter
je crois qu'il ya des caricatures qui
sont pas qu'ils sont pas du tout des
généralités mais je crois qu'il ya des
routiers des êtres qui ont besoin de
passer par des stades comme ça où ils
vont en avoir plus besoin de ressembler
à une femme ou plus besoin de ressembler
un homme très dur très violent je crois
pas que ce soit du tout une caricature
commencez-vous pas oui s'il ya une
manière que ce soit parce que bon moi je
veux répondre ces choses assez c'est
vrai c'est vrai qu'on peut avoir l'air
d'un d'urcel c'est vrai qu'on peut avoir
l'air efféminé comme l'on dit pourquoi
pas pourquoi pas mais ça peut être aussi
très jeune une manière dé prouver sa
liberté je veux dire qu'il peut être il
ya il y a pourquoi est-ce qu'on le
rencontre - dans les générations
d'aujourd'hui alors que l'on rencontre
est davantage dans les générations
passées parce que je pense que le
silence était tel est le masque était si
lourd que peut-être il y avait je ne
sais pas j'avais cette idée
peut-être que deux d'avoir l'image de la
femme en en tête est d'essayer d'être
séduisant comme une femme ce qui est une
grave erreur parce que c'est à ce moment
là ont séduit pas du tout les hommes
peut être que d'avoir cette idée en tête
c'était une manière de se libérer une
manière solitaire de se libérer nous
l'important c'est que je parle de la
liberté ii dans l'amour homosexuel ya
aussi ces grands liberté cdh a su
d'assumer de vivre son autre sexe car
nous avons tous de sexe en face à team
vielles vérité éculés maintenant le plus
froid et de falla la bisexualité il ya
qu'à voir les jeunes veaux frisons
bisexuels déjà prédit fait et
l'homosexuel certainement à quelqu'un
qui a une part de notre sexe et il ya la
caricature que d'être défini nation où
le travesti mais qui a aussi sa grande
50 contrepartie j'ai tous les grands
créateurs
on s'est vus comme des crétins ont
toujours goût hommes ont tous leur part
féminine importante et femmes part
masculine mais c'est très beau noëlla
virenque la société répressive empêche
dis à la petite fille dès l'enfance soit
tu as joué des coupes et puis les
filières sont des soldats de plomb tu
seras un homme mon but sera femmes ce
qui bouge l'année indique soit complet
les grands mythes les grands mythes à
adoriez voulais me tord fico platon et
des grands mythes vous parle d' une
bisexualité originel est le meilleur de
ma été acté que les scènes sont
étrangères d'un moment chacun dans son
importante à dire dans je voudrais pas
me renaud camus qui demande la parole
depuis un certain temps plus à prendre
en compte la question
la question est posée et féminin si je
peux quatre shows that est temps
d'oublier le plus vite possible
d'abord s'il ne voit qu'elle est
homosexuelle comme ça la réponse est
absolument évident c'est parce que ce
sont les plus visibles ce qui sans
reconnaître et la situation du point de
vue des gens qui possèdent question est
bien plus grave qu'il ne le pense parce
qu'il ya un tas d'autres 07 seuls qu'ils
ne sont pas du tout comme ça si je puis
dire je disais tout à l'heure ils ont
beaucoup d'amitié dans d'autres il est
bien évident que si au niveau sexuel
désirent un truc comme ça son droit et
absolue si c'est soit ça son plaisir il
faut quand même se doit d'autre part sa
demande que la sexualité l'homosexualité
comme ton est historique a une histoire
parce qu'il ya des sociétés où c'est une
nécessité ou si je crois que ce qu'on
appelle un peu en jargon la folie c'est
à dire une homosexualité très marquée et
pendant que vers le efféminé quelquefois
c'est le fait que les gens n'ont pas
d'autre discours où s'exprimer c'est une
invention de l'hétérosexualité au fonds
dans les sociétés très lourdement
hétérosexuel homosexuel marié d'hôtes
pour sa fille pour lui l'homosexualité
c'est ça c'est tout ce qui lui restait
le seul langage qu'ils aient présenté le
seul ensemble de signes mais bien
entendu enfin c'est une infime partie
l'homosexualité moi je dirais c'est
exactement le contraire si je puis me
permettre de ce que je peut désirer au
contraire désirant un homme suis très
littéralement homosexue lire en plus tôt
le même
et puis si je désire un homme je me sens
plutôt plus viril parce que j'ai plus de
conscience de mon corps s'est aussi
réduit
c'est aussi un moyen de séduire que
d'être féminin pour certaines poussettes
bien sûr mais pas parce que justement la
société la société nous enseigne comme
ça là les films l'enseignement l'école
tout est fait pour un monde où les deux
sexes ont parfaitement séparer alors il
se raccroche à cette extraordinaire
d'hier jesse au moins si au moins les
homosexuels avaient avaient l'apparence
des hommes des vrais quelques qu'elle
raccrochage encore à l'hétérosexualité
qu'elle mainmise qu'elles n'ont autant
de manières certains joue au dur
d'autres séducteur de femmes le sont de
jolis scores sont aussi jésus maniéré et
aussi du versement
gilbert c'est à vous à nouveau on parle
on parle beaucoup aujourd'hui d'une
maladie semble-t-il nouvelle le sida qui
a priori semblerait toucher plus parler
particulièrement les homosexuels à leur
sang sans dire comme cette
téléspectatrice de paris que le sait les
sens ça pourra être une punition que le
bon dieu le renvoi est ce qu'on peut
réellement penser que cette maladie
touche plus particulièrement et pourquoi
les homosexuels
dr ce n'est pas vrai que les mains
membres qui ont des fils homosexuel se
rassure parce que si elle sera sur leurs
enfants et bien éventuellement seront
aussi beaucoup plus rassuré je crois que
c'est pas parce qu'on a un fils
homosexuel qui va attraper le sida
je crois que l'amalgamme qui a été
longtemps fait entre homosexualité et
sida est faux cela dit qu'ils aient une
forte proportion dans cette maladie de
malades qu'ils soient des homosexuels
c'est vrai mais c'est pas homosexualité
égale sida ça c'est faux c'est un mal un
amalgame qu'il faut détruire parce que
ce n'est pas ce n'est pas la réalité
effectivement et bien
les homosexuels ont rencontré un virus
qui s'est propagé à l'intérieur de leur
groupe et ce virus bien atteint plus
d'homosexuels mille atteint aussi
d'autres communautés
d'autres populations à risque il n'y a
pas que les homosexuels n'y a pas que
les homosexuels femme ou homme est mort
je crois qu'il n'y a pas d'homosexuels
femmes qui soient atteints de cette
maladie
peut-être qu'un acte il il ya aussi
d'autres groupes et ce n'est pas
proprement une maladie de mots sexuelle
ça n'a rien à voir
ça n'a rien à voir je crois qu'il faut
au contraire puisqu'il ya en ce moment
dans une danse dans un groupe qui sont
des gens qui effectivement ont une vie
un petit peu différente
cette maladie était assez effrayante
elle effraie beaucoup les gens qui
fument maladie qui peut être très grave
qui peut être mortelle eh bien je crois
qu'il faut aider à ce moment là les gens
qui sont proches de l'outil sont
homosexuels il faut les rassurer
il faut éviter qu'ils pensent qu'une
simple grippe ce sont les symptômes du
sida il faut parler il faut qu'ils
puissent en parler il faut qu'ils
puissent se livrer il faut qu'on puisse
les aider
ça c'est très important c'est la seule
façon que nous nous avons des mais les
gens qui nous entourent et ça me paraît
très important et je crois qu'il faut
rassurer
effectivement aujourd'hui par exemple
les mères d'homosexuels ce n'est pas
parce que leur fils est homosexuel qui
va attraper le sida il faut qu'elle
ferait beaucoup mieux d'en parler avec
leur fils non pas du sida mais de leur
homosexualité de la façon d'aimer mais
oui pardon peau humaine quelle qu'elle
est approximativement nombre de cas de
sida en france et aux états peu près un
million cent mille ou cent il est à peu
près de 200 cas 200 da surtout
qu'aujourd'hui en france
absolument d'autre part il ne suffit pas
si j'ose dire d'infirmer cette rahmati
cette informatique dire vocaux mais
dramatique tout mort d'un individu que
l'on chérit et vire sais pas c'est pas
parce que c'est ton petit nombre que
c'était pas grave c'est parce que c'est
parce que c'est quelqu'un fréquence ou
fabrice andrieux autre part il faut des
conditions extrêmement particulier à une
police ne suffit pas si j'ose dire
d'être homosexuel dans une suffit pas
gilbert cannes oui je crois que je veux
je devais de vous
lire l'appel que nous venons de recevoir
je suis la fille de justine françois où
dit on si on a eu une envie mon frère et
moi c'est de suivre l'exemple d'une
réussite nous sommes hétérosexuels je le
signale l'amour et l'amour et puis
puisque nous nous parlons de cette
réussite
c'est une question qui revient souvent
qui est puisque nous avons en face de
nous des coupes que ce soit des hommes
ou des femmes
est ce qu'on peut imaginer et quelles
seraient exactement l'éducation donnée à
ses enfants que ces couples homosexuels
puissent adopter des enfants
parce que pourquoi est ce que il ne
pourrait pas gérer via les homosexuels
une fibre paternelle ou maternelle
c'est la question que je me disais tout
à l'heure d'ailleurs oui et je crois
qu'ils aient les vrais temps fait aussi
bien venir y avait aussi des bons et de
mauvais éducateur comme chez les parents
hétérosexuels gérer les mêmes
proportions par tous mais le principe du
gros refuse ça et je trouve scandaleux
enfin sow surtout saut parce que c'est
une possibilité de chances de réussite
de bonheur quand on supprime ce qu'est
ce qui est terrible dans tout ceci
répressif c'est de supprimer des chances
de ce bonheur et d'amour
c'est mon principe abstrait bon il ya
des risques
ça peut être un avantage mais dans le
mariage dit normal combien une autre
attaque combien et d'éducation
complètement absurde comme le père
alcoolique et battent les enfants qui
vont plus qu on a eu plus grave que le
coloris ce cocon donnerait de fer élevés
par des couples homosexuels hommes
femmes des enfants il ya tout de même un
certain nombre de gergy un sondage l'a
réussi
et qui est parmi ses dents sondages
plutôt il ya un certain nombre de
questions dont celle ci trouveriez-vous
choquant ou pas choquant qu'un
homosexuel soit par exemple médecin
acteur de cinéma président de la
république romancier journaliste à la
télévision etc etc
alors on s'aperçoit que pour les
professions que vous représentez ici ce
soir
romancier bon peu de gens trouvent ça
choquant puisque seulement 16% mais par
contre alors je vais je vais assez vite
présent de la république
61 % des gens interrogés trouverais ça
extrêmement choquant mais plus encore
64% des personnes interrogées trouverez
très choquants qu' un éducateur
entendez par là le oui souhaite
ces nouveautés actuelles cettex
travaillé à ce projet parce que un
éducateur homosexuels et ce n'est que
ces naissances et corrompre les garçons
qui se confier alors qui sera dit que
l'exécuteur était aussi en scène des
crânes qui s'enkystent inégal
indicateurs et du qc hétérosexuels sur
le petit fils a aucun risque
c'est ça qui est extraordinaire c'est
que automatiquement l'homosexuel et
pervers il va qu'auront il va vouloir
coucher des enfants c'est l'absurde
alors que ce soupçon ne pèse pas sur
l'éducateur hétérosexuels qui a affaire
à des filles à l'autre sexe
plein de clichés ces sondes et des
préjugés des amalgames mais primaire
enfin qu'il sautait épouvantable alors
qu'on sait que les serres plupart on
sait d'autre part que fera très bien dit
que les la plupart des éducateurs sont
souvent des hommes s'étaient de refouler
qui subliment leur homosexualité en
s'occupant d'enfants qui jamais ne
toucherait un enfant parce que leur
sexualité leur désir il le met dans dans
une éducation une paternité
intellectuelle et pas du tout dans une
sexualité rapide quand j'étais
professeur en sixième
j'avais un collègue certainement
hétérosexuels à tout vent et il aimait
bien caresser comme si elles étaient des
enfants et des têtes des petites filles
en passant dans les rangs pourquoi pas
une manière de les élèves
un jour je me dise à moi et vous savez
monsieur il est [ __ ] et je dis pourquoi
baille carrese les icares des petites
filles dans les rangs
[Rires]
sapho à quel point il avait son
idéologie pas se louper terrasse est
parmi les meilleurs damidot phyllis et
les enfants du tout gilbert est ce que
vous avez d'autres questions auxquelles
on n'aurait pas encore répandue ou des
réactions plutôt peut-être est-ce qu'on
peut faire une sorte de point puisque
vous nous avez dit que là les tendances
avaient évolué et changé au cours de
l'émission au fur et à mesure des propos
qui ont été tenus ici un terrain où
plusieurs témoignages qui concerne l une
forme de racisme
il a l'idée des homosexuels et je
voulais vous les données avant que
l'émission se termine c'est un un
routier qui de marseille qui nous dit
pourquoi n'y at il pas d'autres
personnes que des personnalités sur le
plateau je suis routier homosexuel et il
précise pourquoi certaines municipalités
font actuellement des brigades anti
homosexuels la nuit et il donne un
exemple
aix en provence cela semble être
corroborée par un appel d'un d'un
détective privé je le laisse pour
l'heure ce qu'il a prétendu être qui dit
l'homosexualité est révoltant nous avons
créé avec des collègues de la
corporation un service chargé de
nettoyer certains quartiers de nice de
ce fléau
entre guillemets bien sûr et
on a également c'est cet appel qui dit
je suis homosexuel c'est un un
correspondant de bois-colombes je suis
homosexuel depuis de nombreuses années
je suis donneur de sang or à l'hôpital
on vient de me préciser de ne plus me
présenter pour cette opération je suis
catalogué comme dangereux sata propos du
set à cause du sida c'est ce qui s'est
passé aux états unis d'ailleurs selon
répondre du gunner de sens et c'est ce
qu'aurait pour aujourd'hui bon je crois
que c'est très important que
qu'effectivement on puisse prévenir
aussi l'ensemble de la population
générale
aujourd'hui on nous on ne dit pas mot
sexy aux homosexuels votre centre vont
rien on leur dit étant donné les
possibilités actuelles d'un virus dans
le sang et étant donné qu effectivement
il est plus souvent rencontrés dans la
population dont vous faites partie
nous vous demandons de bien vouloir les
l'hôpital pour donner votre sang parce
que sur ce sens pour l'instant on fait
des examens beaucoup plus spécifique et
et il faut mieux les données dans ce
sens parce que c'est là que les examens
ce qu'on fait c'est pas je crois pas que
ce soit un racisme contre le sang des
homosexuels crois que c'est ça c'est
terminé
je crois que là-dessus je crois que les
médecins et l'art sida ont été très
vigilants et les allégeances suivi est
par contre sauf ce qui se disait avant
au niveau de deux des ratonnades de pdci
jeudi je crois que ça existe ça existe
vraiment des polices municipales
les gens du guêpier alors ils ont parlé
en me faisant des polices municipales
qui sévissent encore dans le ministère
de l'intérieur fait effort contre ça
mais ça peut encore exister
ça peut arriver dans certaines villes ça
n'existe pas non je pense je pense que
quand on est
quand on est peu nombreux dans une ville
de province ça doit être plus difficile
de d'agir contre mais à paris ça
existait dans je ne sais pas s'ils
existent encore aujourd'hui je crois que
les fantasmes différentes à dire on
surveille on surveille les parcs on peut
toujours dire qu'on surveille les parcs
et après on peut toujours y faire ce
qu'on veut la police parce que gilbert
kahn est là je vous propose si vous le
voulez bien peut-être une conclusion à
ce débat qui a commencé avec les
rapports des homosexuels avec l'enfance
c'est comment les couples homosexuels
vivent leur vieillesse là tout aux
jeunes pour nous répondre mais je veux
dire par un regard autour de look est ce
que c'est la vieillesse qui est
difficile je crois que sa dépendance
comment on aura vécu sur tout ce qu'on a
vécu avec amour entre la cgt entend mais
vous avez dit vous avez quelque chose
d'important tout à l'heure de
montparnasse vous avez dit quelquefois
les mariages hétérosexuels tienne parce
qu'il ya les enfants parce qu'il ya ça
bon mais en revanche chez nous quand on
ne s'aime plus ans quitte chacun fait sa
valise et par oui mais comme ça arrive à
cerner mediaset cette loi générale et
corrigé par le fait que si on a vécu
longtemps semble dans l'amour je combats
doivent quitter parce que là et pluvieux
et je pense pas c'est le problème du
concubinage hétérosexuels oui quelque
chose là dessus mais là il sera donc un
peu parce que le sous-entendu de la
question c'est que ça va être très
triste je pense que la société
hétérosexuels et souvent les parents
l'argument ultime des parents c'est tu
vas être très malheureux mais ensuite on
fait tout pour qu'il soit effectivement
très malheureux ou bien on le traduit
commencé via ou bien on fait une force
des mariages qui qui vont être
catastrophiques pour non seulement je le
l'homosexuel sera malheureux mais où en
plus il rendra malheureux et sa femme et
ses enfants savoir il souvent moi j'ai
19 ans un peu toi de moi qui sont
catastrophiques de mariage qui ont été
imposées et ensuite les parents viennent
et disent ah mais je vous l'avais bien
dit mais comment
comme on n'est jamais dans les valeurs
qui écrit ce n'est pas l'homosexualité
qui a le malheur en soit c'était nos
valeurs qui est imposé par une société
marsan il faut être sincère vous plaît
il faut être sincère sur ce point c'est
vrai c'est vrai que quelques
l'homosexuel puisqu'il et puis s'il a
cette chance
cette chance d'une liberté vis-à-vis de
soi-même où il a pris cette chance et ce
courage d'une liberté vis-à-vis de
soi-même
quant à son désir il est peut-être très
honnête je veux dire qui la met plus
facilement qu'ils désirent très souvent
d'aider des êtres nouveau et les être
jeune c'est vrai pourquoi ne pas le dire
on ne m'a caché ce problème
bon dans ce sens si évidemment plus
âgées risquent de se retrouver mais si
on transporte dans le temps comme
référent si on dit à tous les
homosexuels n'aime que les jeunes quand
ils sont environ ils sont finis
évidemment on va être triste
comme disait dominique vanneste tout
dépend ce qu'on fait de sa vie tout
dépend comment comment un aménage sa vie
et puis est ce que la vie complète la
réussite de sa de la vie je veux dire et
du vieillissement c'est uniquement une
question de désir est ce uniquement ça
aussi est ce qu'il n'ya pas une autre
occasion je connais de je connais des
des garçons qui vivent à deux très très
longtemps et qui ont plus de facilité et
plus d'intelligence pour passer les caps
qui sont souvent tragique dans les
mariages hétérosexuels
je pense aussi que cette honnêteté
vis-à-vis du désir est une belle chose
oui peut-être et puis peut être aussi
que si on accepte dans le temps de sa
splendeur et de sa jeunesse de
s'octroyer ce bonheur de tous et de tous
ses désirs de tous ces plaisirs
peut-être qu'on peut accepter aussi
d'assumer d'une certaine manière sa
solide d'une portée de régis personnel
assurent ils
ça c'est la société peut se transformer
se transmet ses furets dans les radios
reconnaît avec les êtres et puis on ne
va tout de même pas sous prétexte de
sollicitude pour les vieux jours il
homosexuels ils ont fait d'être
homosexuel rencontre d attendez attendez
attendez l'émission va se terminer et je
voudrais qu'on revienne aux premiers
propos j'ai été tout à l'heure je vais
dit qu'en 1975 n'avait jamais abordé le
problème en interrégion depuis un
certain nombre d'émissions et celle ci
fait faire un petit peu le point si vous
voulez pas avec les mêmes invités bien
sûr mais sur le même sujet donc je vous
avais dit qu des au début de l'émission
la vraie question le vrai thème c'était
de savoir ce qui avait changé de
physionomie la publier comme ce qu'ils y
ont mis aujourd'hui est ce que est ce
qu'on est ce que dans dix ans vous avez
l'impression avait changé c'est qu'il ya
dix ans il y avait il y avait un prêtre
il y avait un médecin et il y avait 2
dans l'émission de médecins bien ça
c'était voulu faire la même temps mais
c'est important de ce que vous tous dont
il faille des cautions morales non non
non je n'aurais pas aussi tu seras pas
non mais le père noble
je suis celle qui a changé c'est pas le
seul dont dispose la créature c'est pour
le jeune dans votre vie quotidienne vous
dans votre vie entre 75 et 84
qu'est ce qui a véritablement changé de
grand changement avec la valeur qu'on
était dans une société google grands
changements eu lieu le mans 68 moi je me
suis fait indiquer un pivot d'un verrou
qui a sauté et c'est comme 68 et les
concédants 68 les seules conséquences
vraiment positive et durable c'est ça
qui n'a pas eu grand-chose de nouveau
depuis s'il n'y avait que tout le
progrès tout ce travail que nous faisons
tous et que d'autres et vont aux excès
les lois les lois lane où nous sommes
nous sommes justement pas privilégié
parce que si tout à coup la répression
reprenait pour une raison ou pour une
autre car elle est toujours latente
c'est nous qui serions au premier rang
et c'est nous qui tombe en voyant les
premiers donc aux privilèges pourrait se
mesurer
mais je vais attendre voici si je vais
pouvoir choses comme ça ma vie a été
transformée le dire nous les trouvons
que hector destin et on craint beaucoup
de choses ont changé il faut le dire il
faut quand même le dire beaucoup de
choses ont changé et les lois les lois
ont changé
vous allez me dire n influe pas
directement et très vite sur les moeurs
n
elle change pas du jour au lendemain le
regard de la voisine mais intérieurement
intérieurement pour nous de savoir déjà
que les lois nous nous préserve du
préserve de choses horribles de choses
de choses affreuses de choses de choses
inhumaines enfin je pense qu'aujourd'hui
ce qu'il faudrait regarder aujourd'hui
c'est ce qu'un jeune garçon qui a 16 ans
par exemple 17 ans comme vous ou 18 ans
pour simplifier les choses
il a quand même des des références je
dis pas qu'il est heureux je ne dis pas
qu'il est complètement satisfait il a
des références il peut écouter une radio
qui s'appelle fréquence gaie il entend
des voix qui lui parle de ce qui le
préoccupe
il peut lire des journaux dont je ne pas
faire de publicité il peut voir des
personnalités des écrivains il a cette
émission de télévision ça a changé pour
lui il n'est pas complètement perdu str
peut-être que pour lui se pose notre
problème que n'a pas abordé ce soir qui
serait le thème de thèmes peut être
d'une autre émission c'est quel est son
rapport à ce garçon qui est très jeune
non seulement avec la société mais avec
nous c'est à dire avec les aînés qui ont
un petit peu déblayé le terrain mais qui
peut être aujourd'hui nous posons comme
des moralistes et croyant détenir la
vérité sur ces questions comme nous
faisons un petit peu ce soir je pense
que ce garçon à sa liberté je pense
qu'il n'a pas eu les mêmes problèmes
comme doute il appelle les mêmes
problèmes que nous les parfums de façon
s'était ainsi vu plus libre c'est tant
mieux pour lui trois garçons 18 ans
aujourd'hui peu choisit de vivre comme
comme il l'entend avec un minimum de
courage beaucoup moins de poids joue une
fois cette voie et à atari europe
mx wallasch oui la liberté d'avoir du
courage
voilà la liberté de choisir sens bien je
vous remercie
je vous remercie paul veyne de
saint-françois merci renaud camus et ben
omar temps docteur ce merci d'être venu
ici un à visage découvert bien que ce
soit à moins d'un exploit entre
guillemets qui lie à un certain nombre
d'années merci merci dé vos explications
merci également à tous ceux qui nous ont
prêté attention qui ont bien voulu
dialoguer par le canal dsv paix avec
nous et je vais vous laisser maintenant
accompagner nos amis de la rédaction
pour la dernière information je vous
propose de nous retrouver début du mois
d'octobre maintenant le premier mardi
d'octobre pour un débat sur les voyez
aucune allusion sur la prostitution la
post it war bonne fin en soi
[Musique]